irgendwo in der schweiz künstlich häfeli
feiert seinen fünfzigsten geburtstag
doch keiner lässt ihn hochleben
alle erniedrigen ihr sohn findet ihn
peinlich seine tochter geht mit
filmkamera auf distanz seine frau
betrügt er persönliche figuren die
regisseur und autor dani levy fürs
schauspielhaus kreiert hat geradezu
jämmerlich sein protagonist gibt sich
überhaupt politische szene nur gefühlt
dass er menschen lebenswert ist und der
prozess stattfindet ist eigentlich
primera liebesgeschichte
eine geschichte über die selbstliebe
der ewige ja sager bricht aus dem
korsett der konventionen aus den eigenen
zwingen
er zieht in den schuppen lebt ein
autonomes leben
zum ärger aller anderen
einmal mehr freund levi seiner liebe
gesellschaftliche normen zu untergraben
ein großer hang zum super sieg und zum
rebellische ich liebe müh zwei unbequeme
sind und wo er bis zum blühen wenn es
weh macht und zwar für alle thema damit
sei das neueste entwickelt neues eigenes
dafür kämpfte liebe schon in jungen
jahren am theater basel sammelte
autodidakt bühnen erfahren
das findet auch die berliner
theatergruppe rote grütze aus deren
feder das aufklärungs stück stammt also
wandert der basler 1980 in die deutsche
metropole aus der großonkel mitglied
ich bin quasi aus drei basler theater
der stadt theaterbetrieb eine freie
gruppe nach berlin co und das ist für
mich als schweizer so eine extreme wake
up call in berlin erwartet auch lewis
liebe zum film gleich mit dem ersten
mich auch setzen er und seine freundin
anja franke zum höhenflug an
der liebesfilm für kult auch in der
heimat erlangt der wahlberliner
kultstatus
dank der tv- serie vater schlug
swissness zeremonie trug und mit el
abdallah
also ich bin ich das gefühl ich hatte
schweiz nie wirklich aus den augen
verloren und bei eur relativ gut
informiert was in der schweiz passiert
immer wieder zieht es lebe in die
schweiz
er führt regie bei werbefilmen und bei
der tatort -folge schmutziger donnerstag
in basel inszenierte sein erstes
professionelles theaterstück allerdings
nicht auf der bühne sondern auf der
straße all seinen arbeiten gemeinsam
realitätsnähe und die eigene biografie
auch wenn es ans eingemachte geht voller
falscher planet ich weiß gar nicht ob
das war nicht nach wirklich gelebt wird
aber ich lass das mini figuren
dramatisches leben sein zweites
heilmittel gegen krisen bis und satire
jede arbeit sei eine suche nach
identität sagt leben nicht zuletzt nach
seiner jüdischen
alles auf zucker gewinnt beim deutschen
filmpreis sechs lolas
und jetzt lässt lebe also einen
schweizer aus vierten schweizer
schönheit eine liebeserklärung oder
abrechnung verwirrt oft schweiz
grenzenlose liebe suburbia im weitesten
sinn gibt es ja überall und trotzdem
glaube ich dass schweiz gut die gute
brennpunkt ist unser bis zu zählen